that's how it was for me like i lost my
mom at 15 and that was like tragic
because that was like she's my best
friend i love my life everything like
that
anyone have recommendations or of a
digestible version of the holy quran i
really wanted to open my consciousness
you know and for even as a young kid
stepping away from school was about
opening my consciousness
[Music]
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends welcome to my channel
and you know what we might even have
jason himself i think his name is jason
jay alvarez
on maybe he's watching this as well um
how did i come to know about you i don't
i didn't know about yourself um i came
to know about you and somebody messaged
me via uh
dm on instagram and they said the
following so
you made a story um
on your on your story you said anyone
anyone have recommendations
or of a digestible version of the holy
quran
ideally audible yeah been reading so
many books and really interested to
learn more of the story behind arabia
and the middle east always been
fascinating by my travels in saudi
arabia
unite that united arab emirates jordan
qatar egypt etc
before we come to that uh ladies and
gentlemen brothers and sisters what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go and
maybe learn a bit about who jay himself
is and then we're going to inshaallah
after that um tell jason himself and by
you guys followed in this video to him
how
he can have an access of the quran or an
audible version or actual copy that we
can
send to him and we're going to dive into
what he said there so before we do that
let's watch a
uh interview with him on logan paul's
show inshallah
and let's take it from there i really
wanted to open my consciousness you know
and for even as a young kid stepping
away from school was about
opening my consciousness i know where
this is i know this is going away
okay now but get into it i know what
you're gonna say like you wanna open
your consciousness i wanna how do you do
that and so there's a lot of ways to
open your consciousness some of the most
uh well-known ways is uh right from
planet earth mushrooms lsd dmt we talked
about this so that's okay
so just so everybody knows like this is
kind of the the preface the reason why
jay you know
we kind of brought him on i reached out
to him after we started talking about it
the other day and i said hey would you
want to come on and
jay's kind of always been like a really
open proponent of furthering the
scientific research of dmt
which by the way you
exactly there's a foundation out there
called maps right now and they're
basically the biggest push as a
non-profit from
legalizing methylene dioxide amphetamine
which is mdma it's also known as ecstasy
but as well as syllabus
realizing it legalizing this is not like
oh i'm sad or i need help i'm gonna go
get this off like you know store like
over the counter now this is first like
hydrogen is this is for
treating ptsd depression anxiety and a
lot of symptoms that at this point we
don't have
a very good cure or fix for you know and
so i mean
the best way to go about it there's a
quote out there that says you know
everyone knows the shaman is right
shaman's kind of a spiritual leader who
helps
take others through their spiritual path
but every shaman was once
healing himself he wants to heal others
because he was once injured emotionally
or mentally and that's
that's how it was for me like i lost my
mom at 15 and that was like tragic
because that was like she's my best
friend i love my life
everything like that and when you get
hit with a new hard chapter in life
where you're like
like you know the only thing you loved
and known the most is taking away from
you
what's next and for me was like i had
nothing to lose i was like i lost my mom
i'm gonna chase anything i want to do
ever and i wanted to open
that's interesting because he keeps jake
keeps talking about open his
consciousness
i don't know exactly what that means but
he was referring to drugs and certain
mushrooms and
certain uh you know drugs like i said
before
um and opens consciousness what does
that mean you know to explore
uh beyond the limits uh i don't know
because i don't know it has this
effects where some people can you know
go psychotic and stuff like that
uh but he wants to explore that and one
thing that we know about him is he's a
model yeah as far as
he does modeling et cetera and he does
this on youtube channel traveling around
the world et cetera
and so um i would recommend uh maybe
uh brothers not to watch because they
might be you know
uh inappropriately dressed um females
so try to avoid that please um just be
careful
um so yeah so i think that's what's
talking about he talks about something
very tragic which is losing his mother
and as a
a a a male you're very close to your uh
mom and usually the daughters are close
to their fathers um
so he's talking about having a tragic
event and that could really really
hit you hard to losing your mother the
one you know
kind of describable words yeah and that
really got to him and he thought if i've
lost this
i've got nothing else to do so he's
talking about opening his consciousness
we're just going to watch another
30-second clip and then we're going to
come straight into this
matter about him wanting to read the
quran and because he talks about
consciousness again let's just quickly
watch that
not through meditation you can find that
through psychedelics you can find out
through many ways they all lead to the
same pathway as a higher self-conscious
and a higher self-conscious
higher self-consciousness if i've let's
let's carry on one more thing i'm adding
most likelihoods i love is
it's hard sometimes especially in
society sometimes there's people who
feel like they don't have purpose they
feel like
i mean they look at like a logan paul's
life from my life we're like hey we're
we're young
we've made our millions and our at least
you know we've made some money we're
able to make a million dollars
as we said this house is this house is
corrected but it's it's hard when you
see these big people they look like
they're just doing it you know you're
like questioning yourself
am i good enough or like why are they
not like i think i love that's really
important because you know
you're looking for your purpose in other
people and then this word unhappiness
comes in mental well-being gets affected
because you're like okay
that's my purpose that person and when
you make someone your purpose you know
this
is something you cannot reach even if
you reached it there's always going to
be someone else there so he's talking
about you know
having self-doubt about yourself by
comparing yourself to others and we know
the prophet peace be upon him says
something very profound which i'm going
to come to let's carry on
about meditative medicines of
psychologists it gives everyone a
self-reflection of purpose you realize
that
literally no matter your ethnicity your
race you are you literally have a
purpose
if by fact that you can find a higher
level of consciousness it means that you
are finding a reason for yourself and
reason for yourself is not having a
bunch of followers having the money like
i'll tell you
around the world the happiest people
i've seen are the ones who focus on
themself
and focus on positivity really yeah like
wow i used to live down by venice for a
while and i've seen these guys
like 15 million front houses on the
beach and wake up these guys are
impressed man they're not
happy yeah i've seen those guys yeah not
to move don't be one of those guys don't
don't chase money and also something a
little quote that i created this year is
um
i think you should aim to create
happiness versus seeking happiness
of course it's dangerous when you're on
the chase for i'm never gonna be happy
what do i find
that makes me happy create it create it
for yourself manifest it and this he
wants to
have a connection with a higher
consciousness i don't know if that's
something he refers to himself where he
can reach a
point a pinnacle of higher consciousness
jay what we say is the following
yeah is that higher consciousness we we
say that is god almighty now as muslims
we do not believe god is a man
we do not believe god has like limbs or
as a human being
etc we believe god is something that is
beyond us anything that we can think in
our head cannot be god because anything
that we can imagine has a beginning or
an end or something that is created
that is the reason why islam came to
spread the message of pure monetism to
worship god and god alone
and that we do not worship statues or
righteous people
whoever you want to call um or money uh
worshiping something just doesn't mean
you bowing down to it if you're making
something
in your life your priority and that's
everything when you're kind of
worshiping it
um so reaching the higher consciousness
i would say instead of going to you know
taking these drugs et cetera which you
want to explore the higher consciousness
experience what we see is why don't you
connect with a higher consciousness
rather than trying to reach
a pinnacle of higher consciousness
because we don't know if we can reach
that and that could maybe cause
damage uh to yourself it might be the
case so what we're seeing is we as
muslims we want to reach the higher
consciousness but we don't go
through it via like drugs and stuff like
that what we do is we say okay we want
to have a connection with a higher
consciousness
which is what which is god almighty yeah
um if you want to refer it in in that
way yeah he's god almighty he's the one
who's created heavens and the earth
everything around us the atoms
uh you know the trees the nature and the
the the the
the water cycle uh the sun the galaxies
the universe
all is created by him and all he wants
us to do is
acknowledge him so i can only
acknowledge the higher being the higher
consciousness
acknowledging him and trying to live
your life according to that and that's
why when you spoke about happiness and
he was thinking the purpose and he was
looking for
other people who had millions and
they're not happy that's why the prophet
peace be upon him said to us
that um do not look at people that have
something that you don't have
and that will cause you unhappiness
rather look at those who do not have
what you have and be grateful
gratitude is very very important in our
religion and that's the reason why
i would highly encourage you and you've
said it yourself um
um you said it yourself on the story
that you shared
that you want to read the quran we are
open inshallah we can send you one
or i'm going to try and find the audible
quran and i'm going to link it and i'm
going to get people to send this to you
and you can listen to it and just to let
you know because you just said something
about um
been reading so many books and really
interested to learn more about the story
of story behind arabia
and the middle east always been
fascinated um so
i think you just want to explore but the
quran is a holy book that we believe was
sent by god almighty to the prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
i myself am a river to islam and there's
many people famous people who
have come to islam i would ask you to
open the read the quran with an open
mind with one thing in mind
before you read the audio and before you
read the book if you have a
tangible version pray to god if just say
look
if you are there if this book is from
you please guide me to the truth
and you will find him guiding you
because our objective in this life is
what
to reach paradise you know to have that
connection with god
you know and uh to live our lives
according to what he wants
so i would personally say um the quran
is there to tell you
as a guidance more of a story of what
happened in arabia it does tell you for
example how the pagan arabs
prosecuted the muslims back in those
days because they were asking them to
worship god alone
but it's not just about that it's mainly
about god's message to us how to live
our lives
um and also like i said before read the
quran with the open mind and you will
see that it will connect with your
innate disposition
because we are all created and
programmed in a way that we can only
find ultimate happiness with that higher
consciousness with a higher being
so anything that you chase about you you
live your life to the fullest uh
whatever it may be that you have in your
life and i've watched some of the videos
and you've
have a lot and you've got the money and
the wealth whatever it may be but we say
and god
says in the quran only in the
remembrance of your lord
the high being high consciousness do
hearts find peace
and that is the ultimate way you find
peace even if everything in your life
was taken away
even if your limbs were taken away even
if whatever you want was taken away
you will have that inner peace happiness
because you're connecting to that higher
conscious the higher being
and you're living for him and that's i
want to say he's not he or she by the
way yeah just
you know um yeah if you get what i'm
saying so that's why we're asking you
to explore the higher conscious the
higher being the creator
the one who's created you and all of us
without taking uh drugs
and directly reading it from his very
words we believe that's the quran is the
word
of god almighty and hope you've enjoyed
this video guys hope you enjoyed it as
well please
help me to get this video to him and um
hope he can read it and benefit from the
quran
and if he wants any questions answered
we are here for you uh
so jay alvarez thank you very much for
your time if you've watched this and
guys thank you until next time
if there's any videos you would like me
to engage with people
reach out to people do send it in
trouble reaction videos
until next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh